- Rolling, here we go.
(claps hands)
- Hey, what's up, everybody?
It's Chris Reinacher.
What happened to the
coins I already gave you?
- This is Amanda.
You know how awkward I am on dates.
What if I throw up in her
mouth, because I'm so nervous?
- My name is Linda Barsi.
I'm feeling myself in this outfit.
I feel super (beep) fly when I wear heels.
- It's Mallory.
I go, "Hey, it's Mallory,
looking forward to Monday."
(laughs) Black licorice bathed in sweat.
- I'm Matt Bellassai.
This ice cream shops at Hot Topic.
(beep) you and your (beep) baby.
- It's Yessica.
There's a 20% chance I
might have sex tonight.
(cries)
- This is Justin.
Hey, I just blew it up in
there, you might wanna wait.
I feel like a king.
(laughs)
- I'm Zack Evans.
Yo, you ever play Operation?
I was benched for a Golden
Retriever named Buddy.
(upbeat music)
- One of my favorite projects
was definitely Street Tested series.
Working on that, was one of
my first kind of hosting gigs.
It was so much fun.
Turns out, short-term
memory isn't that reliable.
- Yeah, some of those people talk to you
and then one minute
remember I couldn't remember
what color sweater they were wearing.
- Some of my favorite videos,
while I was at Buzzfeed,
probably were any of the sketches I did
with Quinta and Justin.
We all came in together and
that was just such a fun time.
Making whatever we thought was funny.
♪ Don't tag me ♪
Disneyland's the best.
- The best.
- What makes it the best?
- You are a monster.
- Oh my god!
- Hey lady, do you like Disneyland?
- What?
Get out of my house, I'm
gonna call the police.
- Answer the question.
- Yeah, I mean, I like Disneyland,
but don't kill me about it.
- See, even she likes Disneyland.
My favorite Buzzfeed
videos that I've made,
are probably the bro trailers,
they were just a lot of fun
and they're very special.
- [Man] Yo, you excited
to hike La Jolla tomorrow?
- Sounds like a sausage fest dude.
- What?
- I'm not goin', unless there are chicks.
- I was a bro.
You're not crushing it, bro.
(growls)
- It's not working.
(laughs maniacally)
- I'm giving him the nectar of the bros.
- [Man] A bro never leaves a bro behind.
(intense music)
- [Man] There's no coupon
for friendships, son.
That's not for sale.
So, get in there and pick what's yours,
greatness, friendship, and
the 75-inch Tegu Ultra TV.
- Probably the most epic
video that I was in,
was when my friends at
Buzzfeed surprised me
with Daniel Radcliffe,
that was the most amazing
and scariest moment of my life,
because I thought a ghost
was coming after me,
but it was actually Daniel Radcliffe.
- Oh my gosh!
- Shut the (beep) up!
- Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
- My favorite Buzzfeed videos,
well, I did Whine About It,
when I worked in New York
and I was gettin' drunk
at my desk every week, so
it's hard to beat that.
Takin' off pants at the end of the day,
is a (beep) nightmare scene.
It's like opening up a hot, sweaty ham,
that's been sittin' in the sun all day
and watchin' it slide out of
it's wet, plastic wrapper.
- One of my favorite videos
that I was involved in,
was "What Happens When the Light Go Out?"
(gasps)
- We're all gonna die.
- [Amanda] It's also just a fun video
that was loosely based on an experience
that I had in college where we
didn't pay our electric bill.
- And once she made her
way into the bathroom,
that's when she turned on the light
and found her husband's severed head.
(cries)
- My favorite Buzzfeed videos
that I was involved in,
would definitely be the
"Women Answer Questions
"Men Are Afraid to Ask" video.
I helped edit that video and
I really loved being in it.
Having a period is externally
having to look like this
at work and inside you're
like (beep) yourself.
I also really loved the
two videos that I made,
"Perks Of Having An
Extroverted Best Friend"
and "Perks Of Having An
Introverted Best Friend",
'cause my best friend and I
are an extrovert and an introvert.
I'm the extrovert.
- Currently, I'm a producer
and host with AwesomnessTV.
- I wrote a book called,
"Everything is Awful:
And Other Observations."
- I've been out of Buzzfeed for a year,
I made a channel of my own.
- I work currently at
the Walt Disney Company
on managing a team of
really talented folks
to create really cool digital content
and touch people's lives
in a very magical way.
- Since I left Buzzfeed,
I booked an episode of
"Arrested Development."
As an actor, I booked that with Justin.
- [Justin] I will be
co-starring in an episode
of "Arrested Development" next season.
- The whole experience was just surreal.
- I started a podcast and
I make videos on my own.
- I was one of the
correspondents on election night
with Univision and although
I did cry on camera,
it was a really great experience.
I mean, it was a strange thing.
- I have a short film that's
been making it's round
through the festivals called,
"Last Night Was A Mistake."
- I got my MFA in screen writing
from the University of
Southern California,
worked my butt off and I'm
really proud of myself.
- I also went to Buffer
Festival with Chantel Houston.
We had a video that we made at Buzzfeed
that we entered into the
festival and it won an award.
It won excellence and inspiration,
so I guess I'm an award winning inspirer.
- I've also done some work
with the Sacramento Kings.
I did some Snapchat content for them.
- My day-to-day, involves
a lot of goin' around town
in Hollywood and having meetings,
where they give you the tiny
water bottle and they learn
about your life and
trying to sell some shows.
Now, we sold one of them
and I'm writing it right now
with my good friend and
writing partner, Stirling Brim.
- I'm also starting my own
channel called Girl Ship TV.
It's a channel that was made
by queer women for queer women.
- I also have been back with Buzzfeed.
I've been directing a
new Facebook watch show
for them starring Quinta.
That's been so much fun, it's
been really cool to be back.
I'm also gonna appear in
a new, unsolved spin-off
with Ryan Bergara about
sports conspiracies,
so I'm looking forward to that as well.
- I got engaged.
That's right, everyone
wants to see the ring.
That's Kevin.
If you remember us in
some relationship videos.
We are going to be
starting a YouTube channel,
dedicated to our trials and tribulations,
and just our journey to being married.
- [Chris] I also have plans to return
for a very beloved
franchise over at Buzzfeed.
It's Chicken Watch, I'm coming
back to do Chicken Watch,
'cause Keith asked me to and I love it.
- [Together] Chicken Watch 2k15.
- We're gonna find the
best rotisserie chicken
in any grocery store chain in Los Angeles.
- I miss you, guys.
I miss everyone at Buzzfeed.
Hope everyone is doing well.
- I'm just excited to be
back here with you guys.
- I'm always gonna take those memories
and always look back to those videos
and say, "Those were good days."
- I just want to say thanks
for all the viewers out
there who watched Buzzfeed.
I am still a huge fan.
- Got love for the Buzzfeed family.
Thank you for having me and
you'll be seeing me around.
You'll be seeing me around.
- It's just a very creative community.
- Hey.
- Hey, guys.
- Hello.
- How are you, my love?
- Good.
- Tell Quinta to text me back.
Also, tell Keith to cool
it on texting me back.
(rock music)